c'est désormais devenu une habitude tous
les soirs vers 19h30 des sans abri et
des personnes précaires afflux place de
la république en plein coeur de lille
avec le confinement plusieurs structures
qui leur venaient en aide ont dû mettre
fin à leurs activités alors un collectif
formé d'associations a pris le relais
pour distribuer des repas chauds aux
sans abri une distribution qui n'est pas
sans risque et qui oblige les bénévoles
à suivre des règles strictes
on n'a pas organisé ça n'importe comment
nous sommes avec la mairie donc la
préfecture nous ont fourni donc les
masques ils nous ont fourni donc le ged
pour assurer la sécurité des bénévoles
qui font ce travail et après les avoir
concerté aussi des médecins etc
ils nous ont dit que si on respectait
toutes ces barrières toutes ces
conditions etc
on pouvait faire une distribution sans
problème au total ce sont quelque 140
repas qui sont distribués tous les soirs
un soulagement pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'autres moyens pour se nourrir et
risques du carnaval
et donc je savais pas que quels moyens
le moyen
pour avoir mangé en fait certainement
qui de partie
je suis pas la seule et
du coup si loin il pas par ici pas de
maturité avant que c'était pour revendre
à gaza ou encore au tout le monde que tu
ramènes de repas de la manger nous
sommes nés au mans joue bien mais là
c'est difficile vraiment 10 ans perd ma
parole et pièces et peuvent pas donner
et pierre gendron est offert lui trop
faire heureusement pour tout le monde
depuis vendredi la mairie de lille a mis
à disposition des sdf de la ville son
auberge de jeunesse
le lieu qui compte une cinquantaine de
chambres accueillera en priorité les
familles avec enfants